PROFESSOR: So let's
attempt to solve something.
And that first step is going
to be nice and simple and very
illuminating, as well.
So we're going to do a
three step procedure.
Three step procedure.
And basically,
we're going to use
this equation, the
ordered lambda equation,
to find the energy corrections.
One, ordered lambda equation
for energy corrections.
Two, ordered lambda equation
to find the component of n1k
in v hat.
And three, we're going to
look at the ordered lambda 2
equation to find the
component of that same state
in the degenerate subspace.
So let's do the first step.
And for that, we're going
to overlap that equation,
this ordered lambda equation.
So for step one, we're going
to hit the equation with n0l
from the left.
OK.
n0l from the left.
Here it comes.
Boom.
It's here.
What happens now?
Well, h0 on that
state, n0l, that
is part of the
degenerate subspace.
So it has energy n0 with respect
to the original unperturbed
Hamiltonian.
So you get n0 minus n0, it's 0.
So the left hand side vanishes.
Kills left hand side.
So we just look at
the right hand side.
And we got n0l Enk1 minus
delta H n0k equals 0.
That was the right hand side.
So far, so good.
Nice and simple.
From here, what do we get?
Let's write it just by moving
one term to the left and one
term to the right.
n0k Enk1 delta lk.
And this should be true for
all k and l in 1 up to n.
Because those
equations are for all k
and we could have
hit with all l.
And now this is an
amazingly nice equation.
It tells you a nice story.
What is this story?
The story is that look at this.
This equation says that if you
want this to hold it better
be that delta H is diagonal on
the basis that you're using.
Because for k and l
running in n by n.
So this says that delta H
is diagonal in the chosen
basis of the subspace vn.
Delta H is not
diagonal elsewhere.
On the big space, it
may not be diagonal.
But on the little degenerate
space, it better be diagonal.
So what it says is that, if you
want to start your perturbation
theory, you cannot use an
arbitrary basis of states.
Maybe you chose it wrong.
You have to start in
the degenerate subspace
with a basis that makes
the perturbation diagonal.
And that's what our
little example had.
It says, even to
begin with, you should
have started with the basis
that makes the perturbation
diagonal.
In that case, you will find
the formulas giving you
the right answers.
And then, once you have
the matrix being diagonal,
you can take l equal to k.
And then you'll find
on the right hand
sides Enk1 is equal to n.
l is equal to k,
so n0k delta H n0k.
So the energy corrections
are the diagonal elements
of this matrix.
What you would expect.
So we will write this as
delta H. We could put kk,
but to remind you,
its degenerate.
You put nk nk.
So we've done the
first step and we've
realized that this
perturbation is a little funny.
You really have to get
started with the right basis.
And what is the right basis?
The basis that makes
delta H diagonal.
We'll see that everything
is much simpler
if the eigenvalues of this
matrix are all different.
So the degeneracy is broken.
Then things are easier.
If the degeneracy is not
broken, then the degeneracy
may be broken to
order lambda squared,
which is more interesting
and it will be something
we'll study next time.
So that's all.